quinho é compartilhar na verdade o que a
gente tem vivido sobre criatividade e
tecnologia social a criatividade
nada mais é do que a gente tentar inovar
mas inovar tentando levar sentido o
valor e significado para as pessoas e eu
acho que a através da tecnologia social
a a gente possa conseguir viver um
pouquinho disso né porque a tecnologia
social é justamente a gente considerar
os saberes né aqueles saberes do local
os nossos saberes enquanto humanos junto
com os saberes técnicos e os saberes
científicos
então é como que a gente combina tudo
isso é pra gente pensar de um outro
jeito
a nossa grande inquietação era
justamente como é que a gente invertia a
lógica do desenvolvimento de produtos
é como é que a gente passava a pensar ea
fazer de um outro jeito a gente tinha
algumas inquietações pra isso né uma
delas era como é que a gente deixava de
fazer as coisas para as pessoas porque
quando a gente fala para faz para as
pessoas a gente supõe o que é importante
para as pessoas né pra gente passar a
fazer com as pessoas porque quando a
gente faz com as pessoas
a gente coloca elas no centro do
processo como protagonista desse
processo e ao entender e trazê-las do
processo o que a gente passa a produzir
a criar tem outro valor e um outro
significado porque ela pertence há muito
mais
é muito mais pessoas há muito mais
atende necessidades
a outra inquietação está diretamente
ligada à questão da necessidade porque é
porque a gente queria te deixar de gerar
tanta demanda no mundo né a um novo
produto é que talvez não atendesse uma
necessidade e sim só gerasse mais
demanda para se vender mais
mas o lucro mais resultado então o outro
desafio era pra gente pensar necessidade
para a gente poder pensar e atender
necessidade há nada melhor então do que
a gente fazer com as pessoas né a gente
deixar de fazer para elas
o processo de co criação de fazer com as
pessoas é algo que hoje a gente vem
aprendendo ao longo do mundo uma
caminhada de mais ou menos oito anos né
a gente se deu conta que a gente
precisava pra isso está mais próximo das
pessoas é porque só estando com as
pessoas
a gente ia realmente reconhecer as suas
necessidades aquelas necessidades que
são reais
né e também é desenvolver com elas em
conjunto com elas soluções para essas
necessidades ou pra esses problemas que
elas tinham no seu dia a dia é ea outra
questão que é muito importante é que a
gente dá protagonismo né pra essas
pessoas né
a gente não deixar que o protagonismo
seja só técnico lá dentro de uma
indústria né com os engenheiros não que
não seja importante são tão importantes
quanto mas pra gente também trazer pra
esse protagonismo pra esse processo o
senso comum os saberes comum as pessoas
eu acho que isso tem muito a ver né com
uma grande inspiração que a gente tem na
empresa que é o paulo freire né
quando ele fala que não existe saber
mais ou saber - existem saberes
diferentes né
então isso tem está muito ligado à
questão dos princípios do fazer com neco
que é o primeiro a liderança
ela é rotativa ou seja a gente não tem
um chefe no processo
a gente tem pessoas que facilitam esse
processo
em alguns momentos pode ser uma pessoa
em outros momentos pode ser outra pessoa
todos podem e são encorajadas a
contribuir
o processo é aberto e flexível
a responsabilidade também é
compartilhada ou seja não é uma pessoa
que tem responsabilidade de entregar
algo e sim a gente vai ao longo do
processo construir a outra questão que é
muito importante a confiança a gente
confiar e confiar principalmente que a
criatividade ea inteligência coletiva é
a melhor das soluções
a outra questão é conectar ideias todas
as idéias são bem vindas
não existe a ideia que seja descartável
a principalmente se as pessoas são
diferentes porque nessa diferença nessa
diversidade que está a complementaridade
a potência ea riqueza do protesto do
processo co criar também é algo que não
é singular não é de um né e sim é de
todos é do plural é isso também é uma
coisa que a gente tem aprendido muito e
que a cada dia né nos traz novas
descobertas a questão de também tornar
esse conhecimento coletivo é por não ser
um conhecimento de um e sim de todos né
e também visível da visibilidade a esse
processo a todos
o processo do do fazer com a gente disse
que a gente tem hoje
o que a gente vem criando são quatro
etapas deste processo o primeiro que é
muito importante é identificar a
necessidade porque porque tu todo o
processo de co criação ele parte de uma
necessidade de uma comunidade que tem
uma necessidade e junto com essa
comunidade
a gente quer pensar e construir a
solução
a segunda etapa é a partir dessa
necessidade então a gente pensa as
oficinas de cocriação agente coqueria a
partir dessa cocriação se tem algum
algumas possíveis soluções
então a gente materializa a gente disse
que a gente faz protótipos dessas
soluções e daí a gente leva pra oficinas
de legitimação com quem com as pessoas
que nos ajudaram a criar para ver se
realmente esse protótipo essa solução
pode atender a essa necessidade que a
gente identificou no início do processo
então a partir dessa legitimação
conforme a gente vai legitimando o
processo vai andando e pode-se ter aí um
produto um novo serviço né que pra gente
levar à solução até as pessoas
a gente pensa também oficinas de
experimentação ou seja a gente chama que
é um ciclo de acolhimento que a gente
parte da necessidade e vai ao encontro
das pessoas e com elas vai construindo é
esse atendimento à necessidade
este aqui é uma ferramenta né a que a
gente chama que é o nosso mapa de
cocriação né é uma ferramenta que foi
criada não tinha como ser diferente né
então ela também foi criada com muitos
profissionais né com muitos a várias
mãos né que é um mapa de cocriação uma
ferramenta que a gente utiliza para as
oficinas de criação
então a gente parte do mapa da
problematização ou seja o problema que a
gente quer pensar solucionar resolver né
a gente tem as personas que a gente
trabalha muito com a questão da persona
e do mapa da empatia que são as pessoas
que a gente quer ajudar e com elas né
atender essa necessidade que está aposta
na problematização ali a gente tem
facilitadores de avidez no mapa é como
se fosse o recurso o produto ou serviço
que a gente quer criar com o grupo né
a ideação então uma oficina de criação
ela tem de três a quatro horas
dependendo do do grupo do problema de
como a gente combinou que a oficina vai
sempre que é a oficina ela também é
cobiçada combinada é co criada como com
o próprio grupo né então na metade da
até a metade da oficina desse tempo de 3
horas
a gente tem um tempo pra e de ação a
ideação é um momento da oficina onde
todas as idéias são possíveis não existe
idéia absurda
todas elas são bem vindas e fazem parte
aí desci desse momento para nos ajudar a
pensar aí a solução
durante o processo a gente também tem o
que a gente chama de pílulas do
conhecimento que a gente traz alguns
alguns conceitos alguns conhecimentos
para os grupos né porque como são grupos
multidisciplinares
a gente busca dessas pílulas do
conhecimento trazer conhecimentos
diferentes para que a gente possa no
grupo alinhar um pouco o conhecimento
a gente também tem além das pílulas do
do conhecimento
algumas que a gente chama de questões
relevantes questões que seriam
importantes de ser pensada né pra
atender aquela necessidade seja um
produto ou um serviço
e a gente tem também o espaço ele que é
o projeto em si que é um tempo no qual o
grupo pensa e pensa como seria esse
projeto né
durante a oficina também a gente entrega
uma uma caixa né com muitos muitos
materiais diferentes dentro nem assim a
gente quer criar um exemplo que eu vou
mostrar um fixador de mão né que é um
objeto que possibilita uma pessoa que
não consegue segurar um talher segurar
um pente segurar uma escova de dente de
segurar e poder é o sozinha através da
da sua autonomia de sua independência
escovar o dente ou comer com a mão
então a gente coloca dentro da caixa
vários materiais que poderiam daí surgir
um possível fixador de mão
então a gente coloca a retalho de
borracha tecido velcro
de madeira ferro cola ou seja uma
infinidade de materiais que podem ser
utilizados para a gente pensar e se esse
protótipo
aqui a gente tentou trazer exemplificá o
processo né
ou seja partindo da necessidade
identificada
a dificuldade de preensão né
ou seja pessoas que têm dificuldade de
segurar alguns objetos né
a a solução seria um fixador de mão a
cocriação aqui a gente tem no mapa né
o que surgiu numa das oficinas do
fixador de mão de possíveis fixadores de
mão e ali bem no não sei se aqui marca
acho que não aqui ó aqui neste cantinho
mostra um protótipo que surgiu dessa
dessa oficina
este protótipo foi melhorado e daí é
logo abaixo a gente tem
o ano está escrito protótipo um
protótipo no qual com esse aí a gente
partiu então para as oficinas de
legitimação para legitimar com as
pessoas se realmente a gente daria aí a
possibilidade é da pessoa e fixar algum
objeto na na sua mão e aqui
por último o recurso final após a e todo
esse processo de co criação
aqui a gente tenta exemplificar né
algumas necessidades então atendidas
neofiliado de mão a gente partiu de um
tamanho e no fim hoje a gente tem vários
tamanhos porque a cada oficina de
legitimação a cada oficina de
experimentação a gente descobrir novas
necessidades e novas possibilidades que
poderiam ser ou melhoradas
é o co criadas novamente aqui a gente
tem a foto da da morgana né que comendo
com a mão dela é que isso não era
possível antes do fixador de de mão e do
df tiné segurando aí um dinossauro um
brinquedo
edu que também ele não conseguia fazer
sem a esse fixador de de mão
eu acho que é uma coisa muito importante
do processo de co criação é que a gente
não fala de números
a gente fala de gente né então com todas
as pessoas que a gente viveu a qual
criou experimentou legitimou elas são
reais
então a gente não está falando nem de
números nem de amostras nem de cobaias
nada disso a gente está falando de uma
relação
né bem humana mesmo aqui outros recursos
a criadores que a gente tem também o mec
também a partir das oficinas de criação
a gente tem ali
a iaa relaine né
com um fixador de mão que é um pouquinho
mais discreto é justamente pra dá essa
possibilidade
né pra uma pessoa que talvez ao longo da
sua vida veio a ficar com essa
necessidade com essa dificuldade a gente
tem ali a a dona cacilda com segurando
uma cuia com um fixador de mão em alça
também né
a achar iene com uma pulseira de peso
que também foi um recurso que a gente
criou né através de uma identidade uma
necessidade identificada que a questão
das pessoas que tenha muitos movimentos
involuntários ou alguns tremores e em
função disso elas têm muita dificuldade
de realizar muitas das suas tarefas ea
deborah né que também uma pessoa que nos
ajudou muito no processo né a a débora
ela também tinha muita dificuldade de
realizar muitas das suas tarefas no seu
dia a dia né então ali com um fixador
multiuso ela está passando aí há o rio é
esse processo todo a gente disse que a
gente vive ele né leves e tíner antes
porque em muitos momentos a gente vai
até os locais né onde as pessoas estão
onde a gente identificou as necessidades
e muitos momentos também
a gente convida as pessoas para virem
co-criar com a gente dentro da empresa
né pra isso a gente então construiu o
melhor vem construindo o espaço que a
gente chama de laboratório de inovação
social né que é um laboratório um espaço
é feito justamente pra que a gente possa
ir viver descobertas e promover aí
muitas interações muito espaço de
cocriação espaço de estar junto de troca
né
o hleb é um espaço então que a gente
tenha e desde 2014 que a gente vem ea
gente diz que ele é um espaço que ele
está em construção que ele está sempre
aberto né
e eu acho que todo esse processo que a
gente vem descobrindo que a gente vem
criando e com as pessoas neve buscando
atender necessidade
eu acho que é um processo no qual a
gente busca a todo momento não é pensar
com todas essas pessoas como é que seria
né
o mundo de um jeito bom pra todo mundo
[Aplausos]